[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: As a developer,
I often find myself
needing to store data in
a relational database.
I'd really like to
let someone else worry
about the management of
the database architecture,
and I'd like it to scale easily
without worsening performance.
I know Cloud Spanner is a
great solution for scalability,
but I don't have a lot of
data, and my application
generates a fairly low amount
of requests at the moment.
I've heard that Spanner is only
for really large use cases,
like storing YouTube data.
I'm concerned that Spanner may
be too much for my workload.
If this sounds like you, the
Google Cloud Spanner team
is happy to introduce
granular instance sizing.
Now you can use Spanner from
a much smaller starting point
and at a lower cost.
Cloud Spanner is a great
choice for any application that
requires availability and strong
consistency without losing out
on performance.
As a managed Cloud
native database,
Spanner provides
high availability
by managing additional copies
of your data, called replicas.
Replicas ensure
data is persisted
and requests will continue
to work seamlessly
without downtime and
without the need for you
to manage complicated
architectures.
As a horizontally scaling
relational database,
Spanner is able to guarantee
strong consistency of your data
by utilizing ACID transactions
and leveraging a distributed
clock called
TrueTime to guarantee
ordering of commits even
across geographic locations.
This consistency is critical
to prevent unexpected data
discrepancies.
As one example,
imagine two players
of a game making a trade.
Consistency is
needed to guarantee
the first player gets the money
and the second gets the item.
Spanner also allows
you to easily scale up
as your workload grows
without requiring
you to manage complex sharding.
One way Spanner
is able to support
the scalability is by
separating compute and storage.
When you create a Spanner
instance, up until now
you specify the instance
size in terms of nodes.
Nodes determine how much compute
and storage you have access to.
It does not impact
the availability
guarantees of Spanner or
the number of replicas
your instance has.
A single node provides
enough compute capacity
for up to 10,000 reads
per second or up to 2,000
writes per second.
You also get storage capacity
for 4 terabytes of data.
This compute and
storage capacity
might be too much for
many applications,
and this overprovisioning may
have caused application teams
to hesitate to choose Spanner
despite the great benefits
of the database solution.
With the release of
granular instance sizing,
it is now easier than ever and
more cost-efficient to start
using Spanner.
Granular instance sizing
introduces a new unit
called processing units.
1,000 processing units is the
equivalent of a single node.
When you create a
new instance, you
can either specify the
size as a number of nodes
or a number of processing units.
You can size your instance as
low as 100 processing units,
or 1/10 the storage and compute
capacity of a single node,
at 1/10 the cost.
Granular instance sizing lets
you get started with Spanner
starting at $65 a month.
For example, now your team can
get started with test and dev
instances that don't need
the full compute capacity
a single node provides.
You can size the instances for
the amount of compute capacity
you need.
If your capacity
needs start to grow,
Spanner makes it
easy to scale up
without downtime to your users.
Scaling up can be
done incrementally
to avoid overprovisioning
your Spanner resources.
Granular instance
sizing allows your team
to get the incredible
features of Spanner, including
strong consistency, high
availability, and scalability,
without overpaying
for unused resources.
So go ahead and provision
your Spanner instance
with granular instance sizing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]